I can't believe that you could hear me
talking during the reader is my voice
out loud no it's just that you just you
don't I don't hear because my micro
doesn't matter you did that you don't
care what other people are talking oh
yes I was trying to shut up it doesn't
matter I didn't have any rolling up a
thing during the right the other thing
you want to have a bagel with lox it's
just that you don't you don't think what
other people are talking like oh I
shouldn't make noise just let them like
she's not like Kelsey in that situation
they're like Kelsey was like risk seems
totally unaware of the fact that Jim's
talking I don't want to have a
conversation with him about a bagel
right now so I don't know how to answer
this question without being rude to one
of the no see this is where you're wrong
tell me I know you was told he was doing
a live read so he's a talk and not know
when we were doing us right he was he
was doing library I'm going so it has
nothing to do with me exactly that's
narcissism you're like I'm trying to
whisper to her because we're not on the
air if he was telling a story I'm on the
air right next to you know during the
live read yeah no it's not part of the
show that's extra so I'm whispering to
her on the girl I've read when everybody
was doing a man thing or whatever people
still whispered in the corner but I
didn't know in our show we like you ten
assembling to be less than a foot from
me no I'm not how would you not know
that's easily a foot to half for your
whispering ten inches
you literally chew into the mic you had
the thing you were rolling under the as
like literally you you talk for a living
for thirty years and you don't know that
something below the microphone I did the
game won't hear that like how would you
just not know that's exaggerated no it's
not but you want me to read roll it so
you can hear that every roll it reroll
is that a technical term yeah we rolling
yes we roll it is oh [ __ ] what they do
he doesn't line alright guys let's try
again why'd you say oh [ __ ] I'm bagel in
your pocket even smash ah that's
actually I'll take the place aside on
that one can you tell me if you could
hear this okay yes yeah well it was a
God do it no no that's not how you did
it son regular name to a regular yeah
Travis Travis literally had to take his
headphones off and you play that back
that
five seconds ago well yeah give me 30
seconds okay Milo yeah he's gonna play
back everything's about second coming
boy so he's going to play back so that
you can hear the crinkle crinkle crinkle
that was very audible for the entire
audience to hear and it is distracting
I'm sorry but we still need you to hear
it so you can learn the lesson because
it does appear that you do like the show
for many years anyways leave them I'm
not leaving I do you took your
headphones off and walk think you got up
out of your seat yeah but do you not
understand that this is like the rudest
form of communication there it is we got
to take it back we got some skin wash
shows off the titties just full force
when the corner took his shirt off for
no reason
Jim smush the face all the punch you
grabbed Ross's jacket and just punched
the pocket as hard as he could
I got it was totally he's smushed it
good signature move ruining all my
snacks on the road boys this was ever
which was after Jim said uh I'm not
gonna smash your bagel I wouldn't have
believed met Travis you have the crinkle
yeah I'll cherish this is what it sounds
like okay yes yeah God do it no no
that's not how you did it's not regular
name to a regular yeah Travis I took I
was mighty sure she's yeah really loud
that is I can't really hear I'm at my
hearing right right no I get that I can
you guys that's probably where that is
did you see the woman that got dragged
off the plane I know I heard about that
ah she ran past the gate agent or
something yes of this woman there is
video there's this woman and she runs
past the gate agent and just runs onto
the flight and sits down and people come
on the officers or whatever they come on
and they go like get off the plane
gotta get off the plane she won't get
off the plane my [ __ ] so she died they
don't know if she was just lying down
and being difficult or if she got tased
that hasn't uh whatever it is get off
the [ __ ] plane stupid you're one of
the people sitting like they said did
you see her get tasted she could taste
so nobody knows if she got taste or not
if she did that's fine either way [ __ ]
her shoe you can't run onto a plane in
2016 if you if you're causing a ruckus
on a plane they should literally bash
your [ __ ] brains in with something
until you land but it's so funny if it's
before you take off
Wow while she's getting dragged off the
catfish is making his announcements like
it's gonna be 74 degrees and sunny and
Daytona and the none of the oh and the
that people on the plane are basically
treating him like rich Voss does us in
conversation ignoring him entirely and
listening watching
look at this woman getting pulled across
table their dress it's very [ __ ]
selfish it's because everybody else now
is just waiting look at her what a
selfish [ __ ] her eyes are open she's
fully conscious she's overweight very
old a strong guy yeah I think there's
yeah there's one guy pulling her by the
wrist and then there's one guy at her
feet in case they need to lift her up
she's not moving
no he pulling that monster off the plane
she just ran by the gate agent without
having our ticket it just ran right by
[ __ ] her what the [ __ ] is with her big
gut hanging out of her shirt yeah
gusting Utz you know what good just drag
her off beat it I hope they take her to
a neutral I have no mercy for people who
act up on a plane that's that I'm sure
I'll do it someday but do you think
you're gonna you would you think you'd
have rage on a plane let's keep watching
this Adrian you think you'd have you
think you'd have rage on a plane yes I
have
have you made a scene look at it I love
when they have to turn the corner
I almost listen oh look at her they have
to pick her up by Hayes like is she
unconscious or no no I saw it in her
face I don't think she is but when you
when you see and you can go back a
little bit when you see her go by you
could see her eyes are open and she's
looking up at the guy who's pulling her
why'd she blow by the gate agent yeah
she's a [ __ ] lunatic see look at her
face see if she's looking up at him
she's not unconscious she get to
security get down to the gate the
unidentified cookie girl and Malkin
which is played a huge attitude before
she was taken off the plane in the video
police tackled her out of her seat and
brought her to the ground not sure if
she was subdued some people suspected a
Taser so she's been a [ __ ] she was being
an obnoxious Conway you don't need a
ticket to uh she didn't check in
properly with the gate agent you know in
a statement issued Oh in a statement but
bother they said that the pet she did
not comply with boarding and baggage
check procedures at the gate when they
arrived they say the woman could not
remain on board despite repeated
requests by officers woman refused to
leave the aircraft had to be removed
good goodbye
I feel like don't you think she would
have to be tased like something like
that who's acting up and running on the
plane being crazy if somebody tried to
drag that type of person off don't you
think they'd put up more of a fight yeah
than just to be line and like they like
decided to throw a tantrum and like well
fine yeah Thank You Hector told me she'd
be saying stuff as they're pulling her
like I just that doesn't fit maybe
usually she got tased good I hope so I
got a plane you [ __ ] obnoxious [ __ ]
beat it uh get off the plane is a
hundred and fifty other people there I
knew knows maybe she did maybe she had a
ticket for that flight maybe she was
sitting where she was supposed to be she
did something but she just wouldn't
comply with anyone she's just a crazy
airline employees did I almost had a
meltdown going to Australia they [ __ ]
up and then they told us to different
whatever but it's like I knew outside
that gate as mad as I was you can't
cause a scene and I was livid but you
can't yell and scream on a plane you
can't do it you can tell them how
annoyed you are get you in an airport
but exactly you can't do it I let them
know I thought they would they were
terrible and Baba but I didn't go like
what are you [ __ ] you just cannot do
that if you want to get on the plane but
they have too much power now I know
they're all I was on up to TSA and all
these kids were coming on like a school
trip whatever and the flight attendant
kept yelling at and move along move
along do this do that it put your bags
at and I said to the flight attendant
would move along instead of yelling at
him right and they almost sue me off the
plane for my oh my throw you off the
plane he goes yeah he said uh whatever
what'd he say
for you he said when you say he said
what you say okay and I said if you
Holly and they need to said I don't it
was years ago but what anyway don't call
now your new awesome hey I should sure
you should blog this on worst stories
ever.com I've said yes well we would
just be wouldn't this be like your
ignorance the same way these fans are
ignorant of comedy like you don't know
what kind of respect the flight
attendant has the trial flight is no
other you have the captain flocks in to
hear them no you can't comment on his
job yes I can when I when he's yelling
at these kids but this is how you do it
is how you do it he knows how to do it
he's a flight attendant that he should
show people go to school to be a fighter
tech no I don't know the I forget what
it was to I wanted to be a flight
attendant so bad and he didn't past uh I
saw [ __ ] great movie the other what
movie was that it's it from 1984 it's so
[ __ ] good is it the best friend voices
in over his head and he changes the
subject is called called birdie it's so
[ __ ] go with Nicolas Cage oh good Jim
Westerberg toe Foss I was really hoping
you were bringing up a movie with some
kind of relevance but you went with a
1984 movie is too good out of the last
topic like you said be it and it was
mainly because I wonder when Russell
from Jersey would feel right you did not
you did not in fact almost get thrown
off a point yes I did yes I did that's
where you're wrong all right all right
maybe I am wrong cuz you you tried this
young you didn't yell at him you mildly
corrected him you disagreed with them
slightly yes yes yes yes and you always
get thrown off the plane it was scary
it sounds scary it's a really good story
almost show you off the plane you're not
getting specific cuz I don't remember
details or details
yeah they don't matter in a story like
this yeah this [ __ ] movie so good
Artie exactly it's talking about Byronic
birdy brainwash and birdie
are you gonna see the new Star Wars
movie of us I've never seen I heard it's
good ever seen I've never seen any of
them never the original for the first
two were really good to remake me now
the [ __ ] with the Ewok stunt god
you're gonna sit here and hate on Return
of the Jedi I didn't hate it it was
decent but the the Ewoks that George
Lucas that
[ __ ] making children's toys [ __ ]
is a Return of the Jedi also where they
had the sandpit monster yeah again yeah
sure they helped yes they also have
[ __ ] up
they also have Jar Jar bigger that's
never return of sick I know that's a
George Lucas makes me sick and the
[ __ ] JJ Abrams almost good but this
Han Solo's kid was a [ __ ] baby I
don't want to hear about the bad guy
whose get emotional daddy issues go [ __ ]
yourselves young I don't care it was
boring it was young you gotta let him me
he'll age a little bit and become drops
oh yeah Darth Vader was a ba ba ba ba ba
pup yes
Darth Vader was a [ __ ] when he was a
kid though thank you little spit
that's because George Lucas made him
that way then they pretty them up they
you know he was him [ __ ] when he was a
kid in real life no I didn't come on no
he's nobody people get to be super
villainous people because they get
picked on a lot every decision I made
after that sucked
the prequels were [ __ ] you know it was
really bad that Lucas did what when he
re released for the [ __ ] made he made
he made a great oh shoot first
we're distinct he made you put all kinds
of new pushing creatures don't means
he's the worst he's CGI's new creatures
all over okay hey what are the Cutie
walks doing let's see this let's see the
original Celebi walks celebration scene
it's fun that you can still buy a Lego
Ewok village did you know that look at
this this [ __ ] sucks little something
for the kids it's absolute [ __ ] look at
them dancing how can you hate Ewok
exactly dink what's wrong with it looks
like anal warts not exactly that's
exactly you're right they are that's the
reaction you get from one of the
greatest sci-fi movies of all time a
little oh I can't why not look at this
[ __ ] that's fine because the movies not
bad returned I mean it's the worst of
the three and then they [ __ ] up the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] they make the
original Darth Vader look like a young
good-looking guy [ __ ] like he was a
Jedi or he was Darth Vader I mean they
change
what they were the new the prequels
changed it and they went back and redid
the ending but wait a second [ __ ] son
Lewis create the whole he did so how can
he stick if he created he he had one
good idea yeah he's a [ __ ] cornball
he's a [ __ ] cornball I've heard that
did the same but all those sci-fi movies
that come out now are all like that all
of them are good like if you put enough
money into it to make like this
yeah a scenes look real passengers looks
really good excited for that [ __ ] yeah
but that what is that out that's not a
two days before Christmas I think that's
not a real sci-fi movies I just don't
want to see it that's a girl movie now
look at this a [ __ ] long look at what
gets you on the show no in Hollywood
look at this is a pilot show much more
us yeah to Manisha do that's that fun
for you too it's a great place for a
flash fire because you and I were just
watching videos of sloths and you loved
it like another life sci-fi movie that
sloths
I liked the cuter cool-looking things
but you want to see passengers yeah very
much it's a [ __ ] rom-com I don't care
I want to see what we can I like the
idea of what they're doing it but what
here's what I understand about you did
you say he try to make money selling a
toy so no I get that
I believe me I understand that point is
that when you're making the sci-fi movie
and you're making it just a market at
the children it makes me hate your
[ __ ] guts okay I mean I guess but
that's the whole industry that's where
all the money is with kids I'm not
saying I don't understand the business
right I'm saying it makes me hate your
guts start dropping Star Trek is better
like in the book I immediately corrected
myself showed up yeah you usually
correct yourself and you're incorrect
again exactly a lot of times a lot of
times you know I wish would have
corrected yourself your mom by fishing a
hanger or tour-46 ah you wouldn't do
didn't know she did she had to DTS a
dumb tought that was Ravana was silence
is nice quicker I couldn't think of
anything for tea did she that was very
good though
dee dum something blingy I had to rifle
through her cheek did you watch the lit
was your mark did you watch the what's
it with the movie the Amy Adams alien
movie oh that was good
yes I rival a rival I heard it wasn't
good who said that
I remember everybody said it was good
okay then I'll see ya I sobbed like an
insane person I thought I'm so good at
what part is really [ __ ] good I don't
want to give stuff away [ __ ]
it's really good huh calls I haven't
seen almost any of the Golden Globe how
about us hell or high water
yeah I haven't seen that what is that -
movie I want to thanks for the
clarification on that with wet winters
he's good in everything he is good in
everything everybody's talking about
Long Island I know yeah I hate the name
of it it wants something infinite choice
award yeah yeah La La Land it's like
this it's like the artist remember when
the artist came out wide yeah la la land
but they don't have a lot of faith in it
because it's a musical oh [ __ ] you is it
we see there they can't envious of every
trailer that you see for that movie
there's barely any songs in it but it's
a musical because they don't want people
like Jim to be like [ __ ] you know but
that explains why it got so many
nomination hey there you go another
[ __ ] overrated music' on editing it
and i know anything that it's it's
anything that nominates comedy like
comedy movies are coming it's always
musical or comedy right now you get co
respect yeah [ __ ] off contactors think
what they do is so unique and impossible
right that was immersing things which is
great i love ya man
Deadpool's up Freitag yeah yeah yeah
Oscar's awesome doesn't have a comedy
[ __ ] cabbage no variety show no not a
variety not for Oscars for every there's
only there's no comedy movie in Oscars
so yeah that's right oh yeah yeah I for
even at the end of specials you're
competing with every other kind of
[ __ ] variety why not a stand-up
special when it's it's it's a unique
thing to write when they make so many of
them now
yeah not like you'd like there's enough
selection that you'd have to choose one
right the worst I'm just now I'm gonna
rage again you are
I don't blame me for that Irene mad at
the start of the show Frankie wells uber
driver yeah don't put 10 movies now
whatever it is for you know Best Picture
10 you know they they expanded that when
you just expand it by putting comedy
couple comedies in they're gonna do 10
yeah let's start three comedies in there
well it won't win anyway needs its own
category doesn't yeah well yeah it's do
it yeah but even like Best Motion
Picture Musical or Comedy for the Golden
Globes one musical or comedy that
[ __ ] totally different couldn't be
more different
totally different have a drama or horror
right exactly
find [ __ ] it's a 20th century women
which I have no idea that's I'm caring
about for now Travis dog 20th century
women uh Deadpool I think see how is it
it's it's funny anymore yeah I really
like that yeah we yeah I think it least
it's a twist on the superhero movie cuz
I'm so [ __ ] sick of superhero movies
I loved it when I saw Captain America vs
Iron Man I thought it was good wait
they're all the same
you know I mean you're lucky you don't
see that many well I like
what's-her-name who what's Scarlett
Johansson that really makes me [ __ ]
hot it makes you really unique I think
Scarlett Johansson I missed a whole
canet I mean how the Hulk steals every
scene in these [ __ ] movies and he
wasn't in Captain America verbs Jim
James decided Incredible Hulk get off
more steals every scene the Hulk is the
best one because Iron Man is actually
not self-aware than certain you know cuz
Iron Man is really not a real superhero
that's he did what is no no it's not
right and I we had Batman has never been
popular
no he's not us but they're not real
super years difference does it make
Batman as the best movies anyway if you
had a superhero it makes it more
relatable I'm saying he's a man with a
suit yeah yeah everybody owed money can
get that suit oh yeah good point I think
Bill Gates has one you said yeah yes so
does Michael Dell right I'm Michael
Dallas your reference not Elon Musk no
not Shelby Zoe's Michael Dell yeah cool
Jeff number one computer sold in the
country more than Apple yeah dude you're
getting Adele so cool
Deadpool is one Florence Foster Jenkins
oh the Meryl Streep or yeah it's like
it's kinda like bad like oh the most
atypical story of a singer that's ever
been yeah and Hugh Grant early 1900 when
his Hugh Grant Lee I'm so sick of
[ __ ] period pieces they stay the
worst right I can't stand them I can't
stand a period piece that's it that's
their because I think I guess it's a
musical because she's singing look then
la-la-land uh and sing Street have you
heard about sing Street no but more
singing I'm glad that that's being
celebrated sings Street has a lot of
buzz it's a Irish kids in the 80s
putting together a band
oh no just a bunch of course you can see
let's see the trail like Emma Stone well
let's see the trailer for Lalo I didn't
know he's a great dad look at him who is
it that's what Ryan Gosling huh what is
it with you a dancer I'm just you know I
appreciate a good dancer and you Orton
Idzik no no one could've been in this
movie what I want to see the chip
dancing I can do it a different way
that's that's fine thank you Berta
what I know that feeling
Emma Stone just flunked an audition the
guy who did whiplash did this so
whiplash was obviously so outside the
box that he has to figure out what the
next outside-the-box thing is sometimes
just do a movie
and then she goes to a bar and there's
Ryan Gosling play the piano she's like
oh this is like voss saying he's
attracted to Scarlett Johansson Wow a
woman is attracted to Ryan Gosling she's
a good-looking love it he's the hottest
dude ever bro like duh is he really
she's so lucky and then make out with
Ryan Gosling yeah maybe it means
something I doubt it yeah you could just
write your own roles you know write
something that's as interesting as you
are what are you gonna do and my own
Club see they basically made like an old
timey Hollywood musical [ __ ] hate
musicals it says it's a musical
masterpiece but there's no maybe it is
there's no songs in the trailer you
gonna be a revolutionary new you holding
on is a blast Oh Jess you John Legend
fan oh my god yeah so beautiful oh it's
like a pipe dream this is the drink
it's conflict and it's compromised it's
very very excited
there it is
lala land
you know what it's a fun song Jim out of
that that it yeah I would almost seeks I
really like her but you guys see it it's
it's the it movie of the season this is
gonna win an Oscar this is the movie
yeah it's gonna win Best Picture I'm
sure I bet it will win Best Picture
looking at Brad Pitt oh that's a tough
one
yeah but when you ask the question like
2009 Brad Pitt yeah it's a it's a very
[ __ ] a little over the hill is she
better looking at Norton yeah
lala land is like this it's the I'm with
you no one at all it will win it all cuz
it's so unique in and bah-bah-bah Fatih
is oh shut up who do you think has a
better body yeah you are my Gosling can
Isis can I see your body again compared
to my Gosling we please take your shirt
off again wanna see [ __ ] ripped look
at that holy [ __ ] real that's not real
that was not real that wasn't Brad Pitt
no is this the new thing we're doing
just looking up photos of hot dudes
we're doing it can I just get a little
weave something you paid a thousand
dollars to win this charity auction to
sit here in the studio right correct did
you realize that we were gonna be like
just staring at hot dudes while you were
here I was hoping you all right okay you
want to share hotties
look at [ __ ] Jake Gyllenhaal in
[ __ ] southpaw what's his name
I think it's Gyllenhaal yeah why would
you help him never correct rich why
would you help him you know what I do
want to see a hot body look at look at
he's nothing look at that rich holy I
don't want to see a picture of a hot
body you're crazy I want to see one in
person see Anshu that all right I
appreciate that knowledge okay it's a
photo I want to see a hot body in per
your he did once you give it was so
quick that's that's how I am in bed
that's how I am with my shirt off
will you just readjust we [ __ ] will you
flex for our charity winner no flex your
abs I show me a body
show me your body I did already he
[ __ ] came we're done all right rich
the charity auction winner yes you paid
$1,000 to sit in and listen to the
previous morning show yes you got this
one instead which by the way
did go for significantly more than a
thousand dollars this year uh like I
mean I'm talking over 3,500 for us to
sit in to sit in and watch the show to
get the Jim Norton and Sam Roberts
experience well the fact that the money
went to a good cause that's what's
important absolutely and that we've got
a lot more money than Andy Cohen and
many of the other personalities here
word him up talking really I'm not
kidding around this is a big show Andy
come with Andy calling yet I don't know
what his final figure was but it was
less than us that's for goddamn sure so
you're saying you're more famous yeah oh
yeah I would say so so we're trying to
give you your money's worth here because
this isn't exactly what you'd what you
paid for what do you want to see more
rich vos and you want to see him in
clothes or out of clothes that gonna
have a shirt shirtless shirtless yeah
really
come on the chattering I get topless
it's 10:00 a [ __ ] 11:00 start your
plug for ten years I've heard him talk
about how much you work sent ya and you
saw it so just a brief brief moment yeah
I wants to see it Jesus my dick split up
a little bit come on he won he won the
charity auction let him reap the
benefits not after the show y'all how
he's waiting with his phone I can't
having more pictures of me online
because then it devalues the ones I sell
no I sell because the Google Image
everybody still is impressed by Jake
Gyllenhaal's body look at it look at can
I compete with that d-bag d-bag if d-bag
takes his shirt off will you take your
shirt off no will you have a pose now a
d-bag please I'm just real quick please
I need it really I saw what you need
will you please do a pose down with da
go-to move on I already took it away you
please do it goes down with d-bag no why
wash I'm are you afraid you'll lose yes
a headliner please we do a pose down
with d-bag I will say my underpants
they're very colorful sure are let's see
no not like you - are toefl
they're me undies what the [ __ ] you're
making something they made from Modell
there so come I got my undies and are
amazing I mean undies has stepped up for
Sam Roberts wrestling podcast before
can I see him so I might be get a pair
know which ones do you have on oh I have
those at home
wait are they are they Punk panties
really what are those these are me
undies are you wearing the same pair no
no they're different I have those at
home though we should coordinate some
yeah let's do that he's so fine we
should coordinate our panties but why
are they so comfortable why they
different then for the looms or boxers
they move with you there you know they
do I most of my underwear stays in the
other place but they don't they don't
like get all stretched out by the end of
the day amazing I know a thing so
comfortable and they really hug the
shaft modal is three times more
comfortable than modal is 3 times softer
than cotton do they do they make your
hog look great yeah they do not that
really yeah they don't give you they
don't give you too much fabric in the
front so really you know it really makes
your package look really good it's
almost to say I'm gonna get sued for
false advertising someday it makes your
package look much better yeah like a
pivot bra for your [ __ ] eggs yes exactly
they don't even advertise it that way
but it's true say my pointer will look
so much better
here's the question why the [ __ ] are you
still wearing a shirt you can do it take
it off take it off
ground me take it off crunching up this
package take it off we showed you our
panties hold of your underwear this mud
all right we'll pull our pants down as
you send the pants
this is how it starts okay I'll put my
pants on you to your shirt okay
are you a waiter depends on shame and I
don't want to see you - yes you do no I
get by now take your shirt off dude who
do you want to take I'll get somebody to
take their shirt off with you you can
have your choice of Adrian sick baby
d-bag
or Troy any one of them will take their
shirt off with you no choice but rip
probably I don't know we can find out if
you want
oh no you both can show off your tags
while Troy is your respect Troy and he's
not like I respect you huh I respect you
you know yes I just you cut off that
caller
you're my favorite comedian except
beautiful I mean I do like Jim better
but you're one of my favorite Camille
you know did you buy my new CD I'm in
the industry I don't have to I'll get
enemy oh thank you thank you you want to
sign I would love that
I would love that what you want to sign
it I look for what if you don't want
Troy to take his shirt off because he's
too jacked
I get sick baby to take his shirt off
cuz maybe I'm gonna take my shirt why
I'll do it after you the host can't know
when you sign a contract oh yes yeah
yeah but the co-host can what does that
mean you're a co-host well we are you
absolutely personal there's a co-host
Shay my door is a big deal I've seen
your underwear take your [ __ ] shirt
off drugs come on why this is this
Ramona that's right it's in the front of
my pants shirt off dude do it dude baby
come on
take your shirt oh I don't know what to
motivate all right how about this you'll
stop getting touched if you take your
shirt off I don't mind getting touched
obviously does it obviously Adrian make
sure that thing there it is yeah Wow
baby boy so smooth show him how's his
chest feel Joe I said oh why why does
that make you like I lied about not
fashioning that's nice it was cool you
got a good body showing touch him he's
like take your shirt off makes me laugh
every time it really is I don't mind
there is no it's the end-all be-all of
the whole thing there's no motivation
okay can you take your shirt off every
time I love it
twice we know you pulled it up once down
here and then you took it off twice I
might leave with it all I walk down the
hall with my you should sometimes you
perform comedy with your shirt off I
can't wait until I get so ripped what I
can do stand up without a shirt like a
rock star rock star just don't do that
yes she didn't come out I know I tell
you how I'd like to see you do without a
mic
whoa if you want to see rich Voss
perform stand-up comedy this New Year's
Eve and that and a couple days before
and the panic don't weekend Year's Eve
weekend let's imagine okay I'm together
with my friends I'm still gonna bleed
the whole New Year's Eve weekend you can
see him at helium in Buffalo your
Buffalo New York you go to helium comedy
club and then the week after I'll be at
Billy helium in Philly and you can still
get Rick Ross five on iTunes or any of
my other CDs yep and five of those I'm
alleging you [ __ ] in New Jersey what I
call John Bill Self and you can of
course New Year's Eve if you're in the
New York City where Chester New Jersey
area
Tarrytown Music Hall is the place to be
you go to Jim Norton calm to see Jim
Norton at the Tarrytown Music Hall and
Kelsey you're you're all around New York
this week right yeah I'll be at the
Stanton is Michelle chubby guy oh my god
it looks again Andrew and like an ant's
body wrapped in sausage casing
Troy you like my thanks too sure me too
right cool right look at touch him a
little he doesn't mind booty touch on
his body where he should get tattoos
rich ran away with his arms up in the
air like oh you masher where do you
think you should get his next ten to a
little shot he is being shot here where
do you think in my heart there he is
Ross is trying to escape hog so where
you gonna be Kelsey so I'm at the stand
tonight and the Creek in the cave a
little bit later I'm at the cellar on
Friday and then Skirball with Jim on
Saturday that's amazing so everybody
everybody check that out and of course
of announced today that I'll be on the
pre-show for the WWE's pay-per-view on
Sunday road block on the WWE Network
Sunday
at 7:00 p.m. Eastern great yeah I'm very
very excited to do that I can't wait I'm
gonna get boss okay I tell you something
you crushed today thank you so much for
coming in thank you I typed up a couple
words but it was fun yo yeah I do
I did this party you cha you always do
all day and out thank you
I had a very fun time I know this is a
very fun show Thank You Kelsey thank you
for having thank you for you and me too
thank you for the bagel well I was on
d-bag yeah thank you we'll see you
tomorrow everybody